la 12e journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites 270 cortèges se
sont élancés dans toute la France et la
Fluence était globalement en baisse
quelque soit la source ces images en
direct elles nous viennent de Paris 8e
arrondissement siège du groupe LVMH ou à
travers ce brouillard on vient
symboliquement et pas typiquement
dénoncer et justement donner une idée au
gouvernement une bonne idée voilà vous
cherchez de l'argent pour financer les
retraites et ben prenez-les dans les
poches des milliardaires à commencer par
Bernard Arnault effectivement vous le
voyez juste devant nous un important
dispositif policier et positionné devant
le BHV et vous le voyez sur nos images
en individu est actuellement en train
d'être interpellé juste après une charge
qui s'est déroulée il y a à peine
quelques secondes on a le droit d'être
contre la réforme avant la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel et on a le droit
d'être contre la réforme après la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel donc
en ce qui me concerne quelle que soit la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel je
considère que la mobilisation doit
poursuivre le fait que ça soit conforme
ou non à la constitution ça veut pas
dire que c'est bon aujourd'hui pour le
pays et que c'est bon pour notre
démocratie
le Conseil constitutionnel valide la
réforme vous continuerez à manifester il
continue à y avoir une opposition à
cette loi qui de toute façon dans la
durée sera défaite il y a tous les
motifs de la validation et c'est pas
nous qui le disons tous les grands
constitutionnalisme ont trouvé que
l'usage du 47-1 et donc est un
détournement de procédure combien même
ils dirent nous diront que la boîte
constitutionnelle elle est mauvaise et
on continuera de se battre pour qu'elle
soit retirée et donc on a l'un des
tournants de procédure qui pourrait
justifier la validation et le Conseil
constitutionnel j'espère que demain il
va lisera le rip le référendum
d'initiatique partagé déposé par 250
parlementaires de gauche la plus belle
porte de sortie parmi eux le président
Laurent Fabius ancien Premier ministre
socialiste mais aussi Jacqueline
Gourault ancienne ministre d'Emmanuel
Macron Alain Juppé ancien Premier
ministre de droite ou encore Jacques
mesard lui aussi ancien ministre
d'Emmanuel Macron ils ont tous été
nommés par le Président de la République
du Sénat ou de l'Assemblée 6 hommes 3
femmes moyennes d'âge 72 ans presque
tous issus de la vie politique nous
serons allés au bout de ce qu'on appelle
ce chemin démocratique il restera
ensuite à promulguer la loi nous
cherchons évidemment l'apaisement le
dialogue cela a été montré puisque la
première ministre a reçu l'Inter
syndicale il y a quelques jours encore
et le président de la République
c'est lui-même je proposerai en effet à
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux que
nous puissions avoir un échange qui
constatera nous savons bien des
désaccords avec l'exécutif mais qui
permettra aussi d'engager la suite et de
tenir compte des décisions quelles
qu'elles soient du Conseil
constitutionnel j'avais envie de dire
lol en fait c'est à dire bon c'est bien
que
tout d'un qui nous l'a refusé le
problème c'est l'ordre du jour c'est que
nous lors du jour du rendez-vous avec
Emmanuel Macron c'est le retrait de
cette réforme des retraites là en fait
il nous propose un hors sujet si la
méthode qui est employée c'est une
méthode qui consiste à dire voilà les
sujets dont on veut parler mais dites ce
que vous avez à dire mais de toute façon
on fera ce que le gouvernement aura
décidé de faire ça ne marche plus ça ne
marche pas son arrogant son orgueil même
c'est peut-être parce qu'il est trop
jeune j'en sais rien moi mais fait que
aujourd'hui faites un procès de jeunisme
là non mais c'est ce que j'entends aussi
j'entends ça je dis on a
certains disent on a mis au pouvoir un
président trop jeune il orgueilleux il
est méprisant toute une série de statues
décapitées comme ici la Vierge Marie
au-dessus de l'hôtel l'église
Sainte-Madeleine d'Angers a été
vandalisée hier après plus d'un mois de
recherches Nicolas a enfin pu enlacer
son chien Bayou il lui avait été volé
lors d'une promenade dans le quartier de
Montmartre à Paris et a finalement été
localisé hier à Saint-Brice dans le
Val-d'Oise toutes les statues ont été
aussi systématiquement détruite les
morceaux de plâtre encore par centaines
sur le sol certaines personnes au
courant de cette histoire ont reconnu le
chien et ont tout de suite prévu la
police une mobilisation intense qui a
permis à Bayou d'être à nouveau en
famille nouvelle gaffe de Joe Biden hier
soir en déplacement en Irlande le
président américain dans un peuple a
confondu l’équipe de rugby des All
Blacks avec les Black And Dance noir et
fauve en français une unité militaire
britannique qui a combattu les
indépendantistes De l'iral armée
républicaine irlandaise il y a un siècle
une bourde qui fait tâche dans un voyage
placé sous le signe de l'apaisement